Two people in the lab,
a postdoc named Kai Papenfort and a graduate student named Justin Silpe,
were working on Vibrio cholerae because we study quorum sensing in Vibrio cholerae.
And they happened onto a gene,
a new gene,
which,
when they were measuring when was Vibrio cholerae expressing that gene.
It didn't express it at low cell density, but when cholera grew to high cell density,
this gene turned on.
And in my lab,
when something doesn't happen at low cell density and it turns on at high cell density, we're like, ding ding
ding! That's quorum sensing,
right. Bacteria only turn it on when they're in a group.
And so we're like,
oh great,
we have this new quorum sensing gene.
So that was fine.
So then Justin and Kai wanted to understand
which of the cholerae autoinducers,
which we had discovered long ago,
which of them is most responsible or both,
you know,
for turning on that new gene.
So then they made a mutant. It was incapable of making either
of the known quorum sensing autoinducers.
And in that mutant they followed that gene and it turned on at high cell
density just fine.
And so that was a eureka moment because they were like,
it's not the autoinducers we know about,
so there had to be something else the cholerae was making, in the absence of the
two known autoinducers, that was turning on this new gene at high cell density--
so a new autoinducer. And so they reasoned that.
And so then what they did was they grew up huge amounts of cholerae,
spun the cells out of the tube, and the autoinducer is on the outside,
they collected up all that growth medium that the cholerae had grown in,
this fantasy, you know, mystery autoinducer was in, and they did very
standard biochemistry.
They just fractionated,
we call it,
they just made cuts of these growth medium and pared it down and pared it down
until finally they had one molecule in their tube.
They figured out the structure of it and it's this new molecule that we call DPO.
And so that is our newest autoinducer.
And so after all of these years,
there's still many more of these chemical words to find, even in these well studied bacteria,
and so we're excited to be onto a brand new
quorum sensing system in this bacterium that we have studied for twenty
years and thought we knew a lot about. What's really interesting,
an interesting twist on quorum sensing in cholerae, is that at high cell density,
when quorum sensing autoinducers accumulate,
cholerae shuts off virulence and it tries to get out of the host.
So if you provide autoinducers,
cholerae shuts down pathogenecity.
So now Kai and Justin have a new
autoinducer DPO,
and the dream is that you could just provide that, like I could make a tablet, for
example, of DPO, and give it to you and you could take
it and that would suppress cholerae virulence.
The other thing that's really interesting that Kai and Justin showed, is that
DPO is not only made, this autoinducer DPO, is not only made
by cholerae.
In fact,
it's made by many of these microbiome bacteria that live naturally
in the gut.
So what we think, is that the microbiome bacteria are making DPO,
and that is being used in the gut to fend off this invader,
cholerae.
And so maybe another strategy could be to actually get these
microbiome bacteria that live in us naturally,
to make more DPO or make it on demand, and they could do the fighting
against cholerae and it would be a more natural kind of medicine.
It would be your own commensalor
mutualistic bacteria fighting off this invader that's not supposed to be
there.
And so those are sort of our two ideas right now for using DPO as a
medicine, so it could be DPO or a derivative of DPO,
a DPO-like molecule.
And either we're going to make it, hopefully, or we're going to get your bacteria,
your normal bacteria,
to make it in the hopes of making people healthier.